[Música]
eu sou uma jornalista apaixonada pela
ciência
quando eu era criança eu adorava ver
notícias mas principalmente às notícias
que diziam que descobriram um novo
remédio para tratamento de câncer
uma notícia que falava aqui no méxico
novo vulcão tinha entrado em erupção ou
aquela que me dizia que uma nova espécie
foi descoberta identificada
talvez a coisa que mais marcou a minha
infância nessas notícias foi o dia em
que 1000 anunciou um caminhou na lua
eu tinha cinco anos de idade
eu nunca esqueci aquela imagem de uma
bola azul que era diferente do globo que
eu tinha lá em casa
essa bola não marcava onde terminava um
país e começar a outro
isso me marcou profundamente porque eu
entendi naquele momento que a natureza
não reconhece fronteiras foi 92 já como
uma jovem repórter aqui no rio de
janeiro cobrindo a conferência do clima
a rio 92
eu tive acesso a uma informação que me
impactou ainda mais profundamente
eu ouvi pela primeira vez a explicação
de efeito estufa de que nós estávamos
aquecendo o planeta e que isso
provocaria mudanças no clima e o impacto
profundo em todas as espécies inclusive
a nossa a espécie humana
os cientistas fizeram alarme e hoje 26
anos depois o planeta já está um grau
mais quente então um grau mais quente
desde que nós começamos a queimar
combustíveis fósseis na revolução
industrial
ele tem um grau mais quente porque nós
começamos a queimar combustíveis fósseis
na revolução industrial para produzir
energia e 90 máquinas um grau
por causa dessas emissões que mudaram a
nossa atmosfera
nesses 26 anos
eu tenho dedicado grande parte do meu
tempo como jornalista reportando sobre
mudanças climáticas ao redor do mundo
esta semana mesmo o painel de cientistas
da onu do clima soltou um novo relatório
dizendo que as mudanças climáticas estão
sendo sentidas de maneira diferente o
aquecimento principalmente em diferentes
partes do planeta tem lugares que estão
esquentando mais uma coisa preocupante
90% desse calor extra está sendo
absorvido pelos oceanos e isso tempo
conseqüências importantes os oceanos
devem subir
a nova previsão um metro e vinte até o
fim deste século
quem aqui mora perto da praia consegue
ter uma idéia do que isso significa mais
de 30% da população do planeta vive
perto do mar ou em áreas baixas
se essa informação
assusta a gente vocês imaginem os
moradores os moradores de maldivas
paraíso né areia branca e mar azul só
que maldivas é um arquipélago no oceano
índico perto de ilhas como essa são
ilhas de corais que tem em média um
metro e meio de altitude
o metro e meio
não é preciso que o oceano subir um
metro e vinte pra que elas estejam
condenados
basta 50 centímetros e num dia de
tempestade grande
uma onda virou tsunami lavando essas
ilhas
em 2008 eu estive lá e acompanhei um
projeto que está replantando corais
repovoando as barreiras de corais para
formar uma proteção natural porque os
corais eles funcionam como o quebra-mar
absorvem bastante da energia do impacto
das ondas
a outra notícia ruim na antártica em
janeiro eu estive lá pela quarta vez eu
era aquele pontinho lá sou eu
do lado de um alpinista em cima de uma
geleira de outro ângulo
dá pra ver o estado da geleira toda
rachada essa face toda da geleira deve
colapsa
já no próximo verão
essa é uma maneira pequena se chama e
cola de mas esse fenômeno está sendo
observado pelo continente inteiro em
toda a borda do continente
vocês sabem que a tática é um continente
inteiro coberto por um manto de gelo no
centro tem cinco quilômetros de altura
de gelo é muito gelo acumulado
só que quando chega na costa este gelo
avança pelo fundo do mar e depois fica
uma plataforma dessas plataformas de
gelo se estende por centenas de
quilômetros
a água quente está entrando por baixo
derretendo essas plataformas por baixo e
elas vão ficando soltas
eventualmente um pedaço de quebra e lá
se foi um iceberg maior que a ilha de
manhattan e o ritmo em que está
acontecendo está crescendo muito nas
décadas 70 e 80 eram 4 bilhões de
toneladas de água por ano que a tática
só estava no mar em 2009 foi seis vezes
mais 252 bilhões de toneladas
antártica também é o lugar onde os
cientistas estão buscando as evidências
de que somos nós os responsáveis pelo
aquecimento do planeta
eles fazem eles perfuraram o gelo então
muito profundamente nesse manto de gelo
e vão tirando o que eles chamam de
testemunho de gelo
isso funciona sempre vocês imaginem a
neve caindo ano após ano uma camada em
cima da outra e se acumulando centenas
de milhares de anos
a neve pelo tamanho de cada camada que
pode ser observado dá pra saber como é
que foi o clima estava mais quente
estava mais frio mas não é só isso que a
gente sabe a neve ela chega trazendo
aprisionado dentro dela
exemplos do que era a atmosfera no
passado essas bolinhas de ar e quando
esse à do passado é analisado no
presente os cientistas conseguem mapear
como é que a atmosfera
o nível de gás carbônico se manteve
praticamente estável durante 400 mil
anos até explodir a partir da revolução
industrial e especialmente a partir da
segunda metade do século passado
do outro lado do planeta no ártico o
outro pólo
o derretimento já é muito mais rápido
muito mais dramático
a gente sabe que as plataformas de gelo
não vão aumentar o nível dos oceanos o
que aumenta o nível dos oceanos é o gelo
que estava em montanhas porque é esse
gelo da plataforma já está na água já
está contando esse volume mas as
montanhas estão derretendo
dramaticamente também outra coisa que
aumenta o volume dos oceanos
a temperatura da água a água mais quente
tem mais volume e as montanhas estão
derretendo ainda mais rápido do que o
ártico
essa é a morte que ele mesmo e esse é o
monte kilimanjaro na áfrica é o ponto
mais alto da áfrica tem quase 6 mil
metros de altitude e é o único lugar da
áfrica que tem gelo perene tem ainda
fazer um pouquinho dá pois é o que está
acontecendo é que tá perdendo gelo muito
rápido e por duas razões primeiro por
causa do desmatamento da floresta ao
redor do kilimanjaro
quando você tira a floresta você não tem
árvore para fazer a apuração se não tem
vapor ação não tem chuva no caso de lá
não tem neve para voltar a repor o que
derrete no verão
a outra razão é que a troposfera essa
parte da atmosfera onde a gente vive
está ficando muito mais quente ea linha
do zero grau todo mundo sabe que subiu a
montanha vai ficando mais frio né a
linha do zero grau também está subindo e
conforme vai subindo vai derretendo todo
mundo sabe que a água começa a
descongelar acima de zero
então isso é o que a gente encontra
quando chega no topo do kilimanjaro
apenas 15% do gelo que estava lá quando
ela se reuniu e escreveu o seu clássico
as neves do kilimanjaro mesmo está
acontecendo nos andes e no himalaia está
acontecendo também nos alpes na europa
mas nos andes e no himalaia tem uma
consequência muito mais grave porque as
populações dependem da água do degelo
pra poder para irrigar suas plantações
só poder plantar para poder comer então
são centenas de milhões de pessoas que
correm risco de segurança hídrica e tem
uma coisa muito nefasta a respeito das
mudanças climáticas é que elas atingem
principalmente os pobres atinge
principalmente os países mais pobres e
os pobres dos países ricos
aqui a gente está vendo veneza é todo
mundo reconhecendo a praça são marcos em
veneza é uma sobrevivente das águas
sempre lidou com o problema de água
porque está em cima de uma ilha dentro
de uma laguna um solo instável mas tem
um outro fenômeno que se chama a qual
alta que acontece acontecia a cada
algumas décadas uma maré muito mais alta
uma água mais alta aqui e não dava
cidade
isso agora tem acontecido a cada poucos
anos
só que os italianos se industrializaram
cedo emitiram muitos gases de efeito
estufa que se acumularam na atmosfera
estão esquentando o planeta agora mas
porque eles tiveram essa
industrialização eles enriqueceram e aí
eles estão construindo já terminado de
construir eclusas tapando as três
entradas da laguna onde fica veneza
essas eclusas que custaram alguns
bilhões de euros conseguem segurar a
maré mais alta quando ela chega mas lá
em vanuatu na oceania um arquipélago
muito pobre
eu encontrei pessoas carregando pedras
com as próprias mãos para tentar criar
barreiras contra as marés mais altas e
contra as ondas maiores que vem com as
tempestades vocês podem ver as árvores a
caídas por causa da força das ondas no
sul da frança o delta do rio ganges
brahmaputra é formada assim por muitas
ilhas de sedimento basicamente ilhas de
lama e é com lama que eles constroem
muralhas ao redor dessas ilhas para
impedir que a água salgada atingir as
suas lavouras porque o sal impede a
produção de alimentos
nesses lugares onde não circula dinheiro
se você não colhe você não come uma
colheita que falha significa gente muito
pobre e se tornou
miserável e correndo risco de morrer de
fome
a gente sabe que a amazônia tem sofrido
desmatamento ao longo de muitas décadas
e o estudo de dois cientistas muito
reconhecidos
carlos nobre brasileiro thomas lovejoy
mostra que a amazônia ela pode ter um
tipping point um momento em que o
desmatamento atingir um determinado
nível ea floresta entre em colapso
a floresta vai morrendo no lugar dela
fica uma savana
isso vai mudar ainda mais o clima do
planeta e comprometer seriamente o clima
do brasil que depende do ciclo de
evaporação da amazônia para trazer
umidade e chuva para todo aquele nosso
celeiro agrícola
esse tipo em point estaria entre 20 e
25% de desmatamento neste momento nós já
desmatamos 19% da amazônia
houve também o que a política desastrada
de ocupação da floresta a pretexto de
desenvolvimento econômico pode fazer
essa ilha de bornéu na parte da
indonésia
o governo da indonésia está transferindo
para bornéu populações de outras ilhas
criando esses assentamentos e lá estão
plantando vender o óleo de palma que
serve pra o óleo de palma ele serve para
abastecer carros na europa sem o ar tem
mais lhe fica mais limpo lá né
mas está secando uma floresta que é uma
floresta molhada essa floresta molhada
ela tem muita matéria orgânica estocada
quando seca a matéria orgânica virar gás
metano e o gás metano é muito pior ainda
do que o gás
harmônico o aquecimento do planeta
quem mora lá são os nossos parentes
próximos dos orangotangos que estão
seriamente ameaçados de extinção
se os orangotangos não sobreviverem
não vai ser só uma coisa moralmente
injustificável que é extinguir os nossos
primos na escala da evolução que
compartilham de 97% do nosso dna
se eles desaparecerem é porque os nossos
filhos e os nossos netos já vão ter que
enfrentar o mundo com dificuldade de
produzir alimentos
o mundo com tempestades mais fortes
períodos maiores de seca disputa entre
países por água e terra imigrações
imensas
nós ainda podemos fazer alguma coisa nós
podemos acreditar na ciência
quando a gente fica doente a gente
acredita na ciência e toma remédio que
foi desenvolvido pela ciência
quando a gente se desloca os um carro um
trem um avião que foi desenvolvido pela
ciência
a gente faz seguro do carro
a possibilidade do nosso carro bateu
roubado é muito pequena
agora nós temos 99% dos cientistas que
estudam o clima dizendo que a terra está
mudando por causa da nossa ação e que
nós precisamos parar de consumir
combustíveis fósseis e precisamos
plantar 1 trilhão de árvores isso porque
a gente não tá ouvindo a ciência como é
que a gente vai justificar para as
próximas gerações que a gente não tinha
um plano a e não tinha um plano b
mesmo sabendo que nós não temos um
planeta b
a hora de agir agora porque a gente não
tem para onde fugir
obrigada
[Aplausos]